I'm here with Jason Barros
who's the program manager for
the Georgia Tech team here at Udacity.
He also formerly worked at
the education startup, EdMoto.
Thank you so much for
talking to us today.
>> Yeah absolutely David.
>> So the first thing I'd ask is that
many of our students in this class might
be interested in spinning up their
projects to a startup after this
class is done.
>> Okay.
>> What are some obstacles or
some things to keep in
mind when dealing with
the business side of
educational technology?
>> I mean, one, you really want to
go in and exhibit a lot of patience.
It is really slow working
with universities and
any educational institutions.
There are a lot of things that they
need to consider that you may not
necessarily be considering.
At the time you're
beginning your start up.
They have federal laws, state laws,
and you have to look out for
student's rights and privacy.
All that comes into play
anytime you want to work or
do anything on
an educational institution.
>> So what about ed tech when
it's not necessarily dealing with
academia though.
For example,
here at Udacity we do education but
we don't do it partnering with
a University except for Georgia Tech.
We do other programs.
So are there any specific considerations
when doing it outside of that overlap?
>> I mean one,
you really want to focus on,
what it is that you're trying to get
across or teach to the students.
While we're at Moto, you know our
primary concern was communication,
we wanted to make sure that
the communication flowed
between the teacher and the students,
and amongst the students themselves.
Here at Udacity, we're focused
a little bit more on the pedagogy of
actually teaching a particular subject.
So, we want to make sure that
what we're teaching, and
how we're teaching it
is particularly sound.
>> Some of those students who might be
interested in spinning their project up
into some kind of business or start up.
What would you say the first step is?
What do they need to do in the two or
three weeks after this semester
is over to move that along?
>> I mean, really start small and
be patient.
Share with your classmates and other
people at the educational institution
Institutions or just friends,
and present the idea to them.
And try to get a little feedback of
what they think is going to be viable.
And then, putting together a minimum
viable product is really important.
You don't want to go too far and
try to build something that's going
to get a lot of users right away.
It's going to take time.
At Moto, we were a grassroots
organization where teachers talked to
teachers about our product but it took
time to build up the number of users and
after a while, the network worked such
that we were able to get millions and
millions of students and
teachers on the platform.
But it took a long time and
a lot of patience.
>> Yeah, makes sense.
Also for the students who might want to
go into the business side of educational
technology, do you have any final
suggestions for them before we sign out?
>> Again, patience.
If you're going to work with any
kind of educational institution,
they have their process.
And what I discovered here at Udacity,
working with Georgia Tech,
is the business world moves
at the speed of light.
And unfortunately, the academic
world doesn't, and for good cause,
they need to be careful.
And they're trying to
protect their students,
they're trying to protect
their institution.
They have state laws,
federal laws and all that stuff and
working through that stuff,
it takes time.
And the more you can communicate and
be open with what you intend to do and
share with as many people as possible,
the better luck you're going to have.
>> I can say I participated kind of
peripherally in the NSF I-Corps process.
It looks to develop academic
research up into businesses.
And that's one of
the things they really,
really emphasize as well,
is customer discovery.
Go out and talk to your customers.
That one of the number one things that
trips up early start ups is they
assume they know their customer.
>> Right.
>> And they assume they know exactly
what they want.
They never talk to them
because we know what you want.
And they just assign their tool for
them.
And then hit market and
then find out they designed
something that no one wants.
>> Absolutely.
>> So really,
talking to the people who might want
to use the tool throughout would be,
I think, I agree, the first step to do.
>> Absolutely, and getting
the perspective is really important.
We come in and
we want to disrupt everything.
We want to disrupt education.
We think we have a really
good idea in doing so and
we have the best intentions.
But oftentimes their perspective,
while sometimes even archaic,
is still pretty valuable.
You want to make sure you take that into
account because these are the people you
are going to be working with.
Yes we all want to serve the students
and make the world a better place.
But we need to do it
in a measured fashion.
>> Yeah.
Sounds good.
All right, well thank you so
much for talking to us.
>> Yeah, any time, David.